so trick question for Brady where does
the Sun rise the Sun rises in the east
yeah so that's the basic answer Sun
rises in the East sets in the west and
it does that because we on earth are the
earth is rotating in that direction
which makes the apparent motion of the
Sun seem to crack across the sky but
exactly where in the east the Sun rises
depends very much on the time of year
and your latitude so I've set this
software up so that we are in Nottingham
so hopefully you can see the date down
here which is set to the 21st of June
2011 the time is 342 in the morning
which is why it's dark and we're looking
due east so we expect the Sun to rise
somewhere in this vicinity we're going
to track through the sun's getting the
sky is getting lighter and bang there
there the Sun appears above the horizon
but it's not appearing due east not at
all appearing quite a long way north of
east and that's that's the furthest
north that the Sun is going to get this
year and to explain what's happening I
can actually put up a grid and this is
the projection of our longitude latitude
on the earth projected out onto the
celestial sphere if you look up up up
you can see the projection of the North
Pole you can see that the path the Sun
takes along the sky certainly isn't in a
straight up-and-down direction it's
following this very long curved
arc because it starts so far north here
on the longest day it has this huge long
arc that travels across the sky what I
can actually do here though is advance
through the year
I'll go week by week now and we're going
to stay at the same time every day so
we're around about 9:30 and you'll
notice the Sun is dramatically changing
its position and in fact if we get all
the way down to December December 21st
we get the opposite effect we get the
winter solstice where the Sun rises in
at its southernmost suddenly position so
if I swing round now we're looking due
south and again if I fast forward
through one day
you'll see here the Sun just barely arcs
above the horizon and that's why at
northerly latitudes as we are in
Nottingham we're at a latitude of 52
degrees the winter days are very short
this is happening for the same reason we
have the seasons it's happening because
the Earth's axis is tilted towards and
away from the Sun by an angle of 23 and
1/2 degrees so if the Sun if the Earth's
axis wasn't tilted we wouldn't have
seasons at all every day be the same as
the last but because of this tilt aney
in the Earth's axis some parts of the
earth at different times of year are
bathed in more sunlight than other parts
of the earth I guess the important thing
for a modern astronomers point of view
is that the Solstice is the time of year
when the nights are shortest which means
that you're working night is the
shortest so actually some of us quite
look forward to the summer the summer
solstice because it means that when we
do go observing it means we only have to
observe for five or six hours rather
than the 12 or 13 hours you get if
you're observing in the middle of winter
sure you want the 13 hours though 13
hours is a very long time to be running
a telescope for so no actually I quite
enjoy the summer nights and also of
course the other benefit is summer
nights are much more likely to be clear
so not only do you have a short working
night but actually you're actually more
likely to get something productive out
of it as well so let's take another look
at the sun's path through the sky
throughout the year you could make this
same effect by going outside your house
and taking a picture of the Rising Sun
or the Sun at any time of day as long as
it was the same time of day every year
and as we fast-forward through first one
year and now another year week by week
you see this very distinctive pattern
building up this figure of eight and
this is called an analemma
this is the the path that the Sun takes
throughout the year and if we look at
the top of the anna lamina and now i'll
advanced day by day you see that the
position of the Sun the sun's motion
seems to slow down and almost stop the
point at which it stops is the Solstice
so the word solstice comes from the
Latin soul which is Sun and sistera
which is to standstill so the Sun
obviously isn't actually standing still
but as we look at it day by day
it's transition in a northerly and
southerly direction seems to pause turn
around and head in the other direction
at each end is the solstice and at the
middle happens twice a year September
21st and March 21st is the equinox
that's the other important point in the
annual calendar with respect to the
sun's motion through the earth so at the
equinox if we reverse back to sunrise on
this day September 21st
we'll find that boom the Sun now rises
due east so on two days of the year no
matter where you are on earth the Sun
will rise exactly due east and set
exactly due west
I guess it's it's sort of buried deep in
people's consciousness because back in
the days when you know we were
agricultural societies and understanding
what the seasons were doing was sort of
vitally important to us then clearly it
was a big deal because you needed to
know where you were in that cycle to
know what to do with your crops and so
on so I guess it's some very sort of
deep level it's embedded on this the
importance of these things until you
know Christmas for example you know
probably the biggest ceremony of the
year is fundamentally about the Solstice
you know it's sort of been adopted by
the Christian Church but they really
just borrowed the winter solstice for
the for the celebration so it clearly is
even even today it sort of deeply
embedded in our culture the behavior of
the Sun that we see depends very much on
where we are on earth so we can for
example take a trip with this software
up to the North Pole so of course at the
summer solstice on the North Pole the
North Pole is head is tilted directly
towards the Sun it's going to be bathed
in perpetual sunlight all day there's
going to be no sunrise and no sunset so
what do you think happens to the Sun now
the North Pole at the 21st of June if we
fast-forward through a day now the Sun
will just appear to rotate around the
horizon at the same altitude no sunrise
no sunset whereas if we visit the
equinoxes here so back at September 21st
the Sun is just going to cruise right
around the horizon for the entire day
that's the last you're going to see of
the Sun for six months but
the next day it's going to dip down
below the horizon and it's going to stay
there until the next Equinox where it
reappears and moves its way above the
horizon if we look at a globe
old-fashioned globes you may have
noticed a couple of dot of lines marked
on there one is the Tropic of Cancer in
the north and one is the Tropic of
Capricorn in the south and that's the
latitude at which the Sun is directly
overhead on the summer solstice so here
in Nottingham the Sun actually never
gets directly overhead it's always sort
of tilted with respect to the horizon
but between these two lines of latitude
some at some point during the year the
Sun will be directly overhead now that's
an interesting little factoid but two
thousand years ago it led to a Greek
astronomer calculating very simply the
circumference of the earth so the reason
he was able to do this was that he
discusses Eris Eratosthenes and he was
in ancient Egypt and he discovered in a
manuscript a description of a town
called Suren I think which was located
on the Tropic of Cancer and there was a
special feature about this town that was
that was noted down on the summer
solstice the Sun would Shine directly
down a particular well there and not
cast a shadow and he was a very clever
man and he realized that this wasn't the
same behavior that was exhibited at
Alexandria where he was some distance
the north on the summer at the summer
solstice a stick or a well in the ground
would actually cast a shadow
so he made a measurement on the summer
solstice of this shadow located in in
Alexandria and came up with a
measurement of seven and a half degrees
and he figured he thought like many
ancient Greeks that the earth was round
and he thought okay seven and a half
degrees is approximately 150th of 360
degrees a full circle therefore the
distance between Alexandria and Surin
must be one fiftieth of the
circumference of the earth according to
the story he then paid someone
to march out and measure the distance
between those two cities two towns and
he actually came up with a calculation
of the shipments of the earth that was
good wit to within about 4% which was
pretty impressive all for measuring a
few angles Anna and a distance and
knowing a bit about how the Sun moved
around the sky and Hayden had one of
those things to do and he did not have
one of these things to do it now so
interestingly the Tropic of Cancer was
so named because several thousand years
ago when when they named it the Sun was
actually in the constellation of cancer
that's no longer the case now because
the Earth's axis processes it sort of
wobbles like a spinning top on the
summer solstice the Sun is actually in
the constellation of Taurus while all of
this is happening because if you are the
Sun Brady the earth is tilted at 23
degrees towards you and so it's rotating
which is causing a day but it's also
moving around you which is causing the
year so at the summer solstice in the
northern hemisphere the the North Pole
is pointing towards the Sun at the what
we call the winter solstice but of
course you would probably call the
summer solstice being from southern
hemisphere the South Pole is tilted
towards the Sun and Sun and the earth is
still rotating like this well when
reasonably close to upright in fact most
of the planets are sort of reasonably
talks to act up right which presumably
does indeed reflect the fact that the
solar system did all form from the
single spinning disk and the planet sort
of remember about that spin as I spin
more or less the same way but of course
various things have gone on since the
planets formed so for example it's
thought that the way the moon was formed
was by something fairly large smashing
into the earth and knocking a chunk of
the earth out
and obviously the direction in which
that impact occurred could well have
tipped the axis one way or the other
so although the planets sort of remember
how the solar system formed in that
their axes tend to be pointed more or
less the same they seem to have the same
kind of spin as a solar system they all
have had sort of subsequent history
which is not them about a bit so for
thousands of years not to go over the
top but astronomy was one of the first
and most fundamental sciences imagine
the power that astronomers had being
able to predict the times of the seasons
when the Sun would
solar eclipses that sort of thing and
you can see this in civilizations around
the world people building gigantic
monuments or kinds of observatories that
would actually track and help calculate
these things so case in point of course
one very famous one in the UK is
Stonehenge and Stonehenge is very famous
at the summer solstice because the
people who built is knew exactly where
on the horizon on that particular day
the Sun was going to rise and so they
built it so that if you're standing in
the centre looking out the entrance
you'll see the Sun rising at a
particular point